je vous propose de parler d'abord de
votre résultat à vous qui est large très
large
c'est un très beau résultat
73,13% en tête dans toutes les communes
c'est un une grande confiance je crois
effectivement c'est une satisfaction
d'équipe que je partage bien sûr avec ma
vidéo Mélanie lepoutier et puis j'ai
évidemment une tendresse particulière
pour le résultat de la ville de Bayeux
puisque j'atteins 78% des voix ça fait
38 ans que les Bayeux avec fidélité
scrutin après scrutin m'accordent leur
confiance je sais que c'est une vraie
confiance ils savent que c'est une
confiance partagée j'y vois une preuve
d'affection pour ne pas dire une preuve
d'amour votre explication c'est ça c'est
cette affection cette confiance c'est
une confiance c'est le fait je pense ils
savent que je suis sur vraiment tous les
dossiers pour essayer de de les aider au
maximum que ce soit individuellement que
ce soit dans les enjeux évidemment de la
collectivité et je pense que c'est un
sentiment bien effectivement très très
partagé et quel que soit évidemment les
catégories les personnes concernés que
ce soit dans tous les quartiers de la
ville c'est une réalité que je sens ne
serait ce que on me promenant
physiquement dans la vie au niveau
départemental avec une vague bleue
nationale la majorité reste en place
c'est une grosse satisfaction
parce que soyons clairs le découpage qui
a été fait a été fait par les
socialistes pour les socialistes et
l'objectif était de renverser la
majorité des partenaires donc ce premier
objectif n'est pas atteint la majorité
départementale n'est pas renversée et
qui plus est la majorité départementale
sort renforcée et donc c'est un très
très beau résultat me semble-t-il pour
tout le département pour toute la
majorité départementale et pour avoir
comme je l'ai dit un peu pendant cette
campagne une voix forte pour le
département du Calvados à un moment ou
des enjeux considérables sont devant
nous vous conforter cette majorité
départementale c'était important pour la
suite pour pourquoi à quoi va servir
cette majorité des départementales et en
plus si vous voulez soit nucléaire
l'environnement
département aujourd'hui dans la France
entière est un environnement extrêmement
complexe extrêmement complexe parce que
l'activité économique n'est pas là que
les ressources liées aux taxes et à la
fiscalité sont faibles et on diminution
pour un certain nombre d'entre elles
c'est difficile parce que l'État
français prélève de l'argent sur des
dotations qu'il avait l'habitude de
donner dans des conditions tout à fait
importantes et le même gouvernement
français mais des charges
supplémentaires pour les départements
faut pas être grand clair pour savoir
que c'est une situation effectivement
très difficile et vous aurez par exemple
un certain nombre de départements je
pense au département de montagne du
Massif central qui vont se retrouver
très rapidement confrontés à des
situations financières tout à fait
extrêmes dans ce contexte là il faut
naturellement prendre un certain nombre
de décisions de décisions courageuses
nous avons la majorité sortante nous
avons commencé à le faire et nous avons
besoin évidemment de continuer à le
faire car je ne vois pas un
environnement qui change dans les deux à
trois ans qui viennent et pour cela
effectivement avoir une majorité
renforcée c'est quelque chose
d'important et je sens bien chez tous
les collègues de cette majorité les
qualités que j'avais décrites comme
nécessaire pour effectivement être
demain conseiller départemental je
disais il faut des compétents il faut
des élus justes il faut des élus
efficaces alors compétent simplement
parce que vous avez bien compris il y a
une vraie complexité de cet
environnement à traiter juste parce que
quand vous prenez des décisions
courageuses il faut les prendre avec
justesse et avec justice et efficace
nous ne sommes plus dans la période on
peut penser qu'en attendant une partie
des problèmes seront résolus les
problèmes sont là ils sont immédiats ils
sont intenses ils peuvent même être
certainement quelquefois brutaux il faut
donc des vraies réponses à apporter
fustèle difficile à prendre